rejoignez-moi sur patreon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des coursant visaux
des apérophyos un moyen simple de
soutenir mon travail tout en vous
donnant matière à penser je vous attends
sur patreon le lien est dans la
description bonjour à tous aujourd'hui
on va parler de jéréy benentam et de
l'égoïsme si j'ai décidé de vous parler
de jéréy benentam aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'à ce jour je ne lui ai consacré
qu'un seul épisode
cétait il y a environ 4 ans et un seul
épisode c'est évidemment insuffisant
puisqueam est le représentant d'un
mouvement qui a fait date dans
l'histoire de la philosopie
l'utilitarismeautant que l'épisode que
je lui consacré éta reltivement court
mais il y a une autre raison pour
laquelle j'ai souhaité par de benam
aujourd'hui c'est parce que c'est un
philosophe qui est trs souvent
caricaturé pour ne pas dire déé auquel
on fait ce qu'il ne dit pas
voir auquel on fait dire ce qu'il
conteste lui-même ce qui est quand même
le comble de la malhonnêteté attribuer à
un penseur des positions qu'il réfute
explicitement et on va voir dans un
instant à quoi je fais allusion mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est que si on
prête à benentam des idées qui ne sont
pas les siennes il y a malgré tout dans
ces idées qu'on lui prête un fond de
vérité or vous le savez il y a pire que
le mensonge il y a la demi- vérité car
la demi-vérité est beaucoup plus
difficile à détecter que le mensonge
intégral et s'agissant de mentam sur
quoi porte la demi-vérité
elle porte sur la question de l'égoïsme
on nous dit bentam prône
l'égoïsme l'utilitarisme prône l'égoïsme
et s'il prône l'égoïsme c'est la porte
ouverte à toutes les dérives c'est la
porte ouverte à l'écrasement des faibles
c'est la porte ouverte à la loi du plus
fort voire au totalitarisme et bien
soyons très clair tout ça c'est faux
l'utilitarisme ne prône pas l'égoïsme
l'utilitarisme admet l'existence de
l'égoïsme l'utilitarisme reconnaît
l'égoïsme et oui mais c'est pas la même
chose reconnaître l'égoïsme et le proner
ça conduit à des conclusions très
différentes donc c'est là que se situe
le
demi-mensonge et surtout il se situe
dans le fait que pour bentam l'égoïsme
n'est pas une finalité en soi c'est un
point de départ il faut partir de
l'égoïsme de l'homme pour ensuite
dépasser cet égoïsme la devise de
l'utilitarisme c'est la maximisation du
plaisir du plaisir de qui du plus grand
nombre du plaisir pour soi mais aussi du
plaisir pour les autres autres donc
juste avec ces éléments on constate
qu'on est quand même très loin d'une
apologie de
l'égoïsme et à ce problème s'en ajoute
un autre qui est de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on appelle
l'égoïsme parce que vous allez voir que
c'est loin d'être évident et donc tout
l'enjeu de cet épisode le double enjeu
devrais-je dire ça va être de savoir
premièrement qu'est-ce que l'égoïsme
selon bentam et deuxièmement quelle est
la place de cet égoïsme dans sa
philosophie alors on va rentrer
directement dans le vif du sujet en
exposant ce que nous dit Bantam à propos
de l'égoïsme donc je précise que pour
cette analyse je vais essentiellement
m'appuyer sur son livre déontologie ou
science de la morale publié en 1834
ouvrage Postume donc puisque bentam est
mort en
1832 et ce livre c'est un peu la
synthèse finale de sa pensée sa version
la plus aboutie or dans cet ouvrage que
nous dit mintam à propos de l'égoïsme il
nous dit que c'est je cite la première
loi de notre nature l'égoïsme est la
première loi de notre nature et comment
est-ce qu'il définit l'égoïsme il le
définit comme la recherche de son propre
bonheur ou de son propre plaisir puisque
pour Bentham bonheur et plaisir c'est la
même chose on y reviendra il donne un
autre nom à l'égoïsme il appelle ça
l'intérêt
l'égoïsme c'est la défense de ses
intérêts et donc si on admet qu'il n'y a
pas d'intérêt plus élevé que notre
bonheur personnel être égoïste c'est
tout simplement rechercher son propre
bonheur alors déjà on s'aperçoit d'une
chose qui est que dire ça ça n'a rien de
très choquant en tout cas c'est beaucoup
moins choquant que ce qu'on aurait pu
imaginer parce que si l'égoïsme c'est
simplement le fait de vouloir maximiser
son plaisir bah tout le monde est
égoïste et bien c'est exactement ce que
nous dit
benentam nous sommes tous égoïstes au
sens où nous sommes tous en quête de
plaisir et évidemment la question qui
doit se poser c'est qu'est-ce qu'il y a
de mal à ça en quoi est-ce un mal en
quoi est-ce une faute morale d'aspirer à
son propre
plaisir parce que de deux choses l'une
ou bien il est condamnable aller vers le
plaisir et dans ce cas-là nous sommes
tous coupables ou bien ce n'est pas
condamnable et dans ce cas-là il faut
arrêter de condamner
l'égoïsme donc d'où vient le problème
avec
l'égoïsme et bien il vient de la
connotation de ce mot
égoïsme autrement dit ce qu'on condamne
habituellement dans l'égoïsme ce n'est
pas l'égoïsme lui-même c'est la
signification morale et symbolique qu'on
lui accolle
parce que dans l'esprit de la plupart
des gens être égoïste ce n'est pas
simplement rechercher le plaisir c'est
être indifférent aux autres
c'est ne pas être sensible à la
souffrance des autres ou à leur volonté
ou à leur
intérêt la conception commune de
l'égoïsme c'est d'y voir une tendance à
exclure l'autre pour la plupart des gens
l'égoïsme ce n'est pas penser à soi ni
même penser d'abord à soi
c'est ne penser qu'à soi mais sauf que
ça nous dit Bentham c'est une vision
caricaturale de
l'éegooïsme vision caricaturale de
l'égoïsme qui conduit à la vision
caricaturale de l'utilitarisme que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure et c'est
justement pour ça que bentam préfère
employer le mot intérêt plutôt que le
mot égoïsme pour montrer qu'il y a une
différence entre rechercher son plaisir
personnel et le rechercher au détriment
de l'autre on peut être soucieux de son
propre intérêt sans être égoïste au sens
d'exclure l'autre ou de le nier on peut
être soucieux de son intérêt tout en
étant soucieux de l'intérêt des autres
c'est pas contradictoire mais l'ennui
c'est que dans les fait servir ses
intérêts passe pour de l'égoïsme et il
est là le problème parce qu'encore une
fois pour benentam tout le monde sert
ses intérêts il n'y a pas un être humain
qui échappe à cette loi
d'intérêt vivre c'est servir son intérêt
manger respirer dormir c'est servir son
intérêt notre intérêt premier est
d'ordre biologique la survie nous sommes
des êtres programmés pour la survie et
une fois notre survie assurée notre
intérêt c'est d'être heureux donc dans
l'ordre des priorités survie et
bonheur être et bien-être est-ce est-ce
qu'on peut en faire reproche à l'être
humain est-ce qu'on peut reprocher à un
être programmé pour aller vers le
plaisir et pour fuir la douleur d'aller
vers le plaisir et de fuir la douleur ça
n'a pas de sens donc pour bentam
l'égoïsme n'est pas quelque chose de
honteux si par égoïsme on entend
défendre ses intérêts et si par intérêt
on entend la recherche du plaisir bentam
voit dans les critiques qui sont faites
à cette notion d'intérêt l'héritage de
la morale chrétienne de la morale
religieuse en général j'ai déjà
l'occasion de le dire dans mon épisode
sur la Fargue ne pas sous-estimer
l'héritage culturel et moral de la
religion y compris à une époque où la
religion noccupe plus le devant de la
scène ce que nous dit MAM c'est que la
religion associe la recherche du plaisir
au vice et à l'inverse elle associe la
souffrance à la vertu rechercher le
plaisir aller vers le plaisir c'est mal
vu par la religion c'est même pas que
c'est mal vu c'est que ça porte un nom
le péché tout ce qui a à voir avec les
plaisirs du corps tout ce qui a à voir
avec l' sens avec la chair et frappé du
saut de la
dépravation dans une morale chrétienne
être vertueux c'est quoi c'est renoncer
c'est résister résister à la tentation
c'est
lutter voyez tout ce champ de la
contrainte les principales vertus
morales dans la religion chrétienne
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
l'abnégation c'est la privation c'est le
sacrifice y compris le sacrifice de sa
vie et c'est normal puisque le
christianisme est fondé sur la figure du
martyre le martyre c'est celui qui
accepte de mourir au nom d'un idéal
supérieur au point que ce que finisse
par adorer les religions ce ne sont plus
les vertus du martyre c'est le martyre
lui-même le statut du martyre il a
souffert c'est la preuve qu'il était
meilleur que les autres il s'est
sacrifié il mérite qu'on s'agenouille
devant lui la morale chrétienne c'est la
morale du martyre qui non seulement se
détourne des plaisirs terrestres mais
même qui va vers la
souffrance c'est la figure du Christ le
Christ que l'Église nous présente comme
un être asexué
un être indifférent au plaisir terrestre
indifférent aux tentations charnelles le
Christ qui cumule toutes les souffrances
morales trahi par Judas accusé à tort
mort sur la croix à l'issue de plusieurs
heures de torture c'est d'ailleurs de là
que vient l'expression la Passion du
Christ quand on dit la Passion du Christ
la passion n'est pas la flamme
intérieure ce n'est pas l'amour du
Christ la passion du Christ c'est la
souffrance du Christ passion passif la
passion c'est ce qu'on subit et
d'ailleurs en vieux français souffrir
voulait dire subir comme quand on disait
souffrez que je vous
contredise supportez que je vous
contredise tout est dit il faut
supporter il faut
endurer donc une religion fondée sur la
passion du Fils de Dieu autrement dit
sur la souffrance et la mise à mort de
l'élu parmi les élus c'est une religion
condamnée à ne pouvoir trouver de la
vertu que dans le
sacrifice parce que la religion est
fondée sur des archétypes parce que la
mort d'un innocent c'est l'archétype de
l'injustice parce que l'injustice c'est
ce qui mobilise l'âme des vertueux et
que donc si on veut mobiliser l'âme des
vertueux il faut leur donner un martyre
la boucle bouclée
comment se fait-il que le symbole du
christianisme soit une croix la croix
c'est pas le symbole du Christ le
symbole du Christ c'est le poisson parce
qu'en grec poisson se disait ictus et
que ictus c'est l'acronyme de Jesus
Christos teuos so qui veut dire
Jésus-Christ Fils de Dieu
Sauveur donc les chrétiens utilisaient
un poisson pour se reconnaître entre eux
la croix ce n'est pas le symbole du
Christ c'est le symbole du
martyre transposer ça dans les autres
communautés religieuse ou ethnique et
imaginez ce que ça donnerait si leur
signe de ralliment représentait
l'instrument par lequel ils ont été
torturés on trouverait ça très Glo alors
oui ça a une fonction la croix symbolise
le sacrifice qui représente le rachat de
l'humanité et de ses péchés très bien il
s'agit pas de dire que ce symbole n'a
pas de valeur il s'agit de dire que ça
ne témoigne pas d'un élan spontané vers
le bonheur terrestre le principe du
christianisme c'est souffre tu seras
heureux dans l'au-delà souffre parce que
celui qui souffre ici et maintenant sera
récompensé pour
l'éternité les derniers seront les
premiers Marc
1031 et comme les sociétés ont la morale
de leur religion les sociétés
européennes la morale du martyre y
compris les non religieux y compris les
athés les athés qui ne croient pas en
Dieu mais dont les schémas moraux sont
dictés par la logique
sacrificielle je dois sacrifier mes
intérêts pour prouver que ma cause est
juste je dois souffrir pour que
l'humanité me remercie d'endosser cette
souffrance on retrouve ça avec le
syndrome du Sauveur celui qui veut
sauver l'autre de lui-même celui à qui
personne n' rien demandé mais qui se
sent l'obligation pour ne pas dire qui
se sent la mission intérieure
d'intervenir pour aider son prochain
pour l'aider selon sa propre conception
du bien donc l'héritage culturel de la
morale chrétienne ne s'arrête pas aux
portes de
l'athéisme et donc ce que nous dit benam
c'est que la morale traditionnelle
européenne qu'elle soit religieuse ou
pas est orientée vers l'impératif de
souffrance
vers l'ascétisme pour ne pas dire vers
le
masochisme je rappelle que l'ascétisme
c'est le culte de la privation la 16
c'est l'idée que plus on renonce au
plaisir plus on renonce au corps et plus
on renonce au corps plus on élève son
esprit plus on élève son esprit vers
Dieu donc la 7 c'est celui pour qui la
souffrance physique est le pilier de la
vertu le masochisme c'est un pas su
élémentaire c'est le fait de tirer une
jouissance de cette souffrance c'est
pour ça qu'on appelle ça une perversion
parce qu'étimologiquement perversion ça
veut dire
retournement le retournement de la
souffrance en
jouissance bien pour Bentham on est
typiquement là-dedans avec la morale
traditionnelle la morale traditionnelle
c'est-à-dire la morale européenne issue
du
christianisme une morale de la privation
une morale
de
l'abnégation une morale qui sacralise la
souffrance et c'est là que bentam va
remarquer quelque chose quelque chose
qui va lui faire dire que cette morale
traditionnelle renferme énormément
d'hypocrisie pour ne pas dire renferme
une contradiction quelle est cette
contradiction et bien c'est le fait que
derrière son culte de la souffrance la
morale traditionnelle a en réalité
exactement le même objectif que
l'utilitarisme à savoir la maximisation
du bonheur qu'est-ce qui lui fait dire
ça rappelez-vous ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure on a dit que dans une
perspective chrétienne il fallait
renoncer au plaisir d'ici bas au plaisir
d'ici bas c'est-à-dire au vice au péchés
parce que c'est la condition pour
obtenir son accès au Paradis or
qu'est-ce qui nous est promis à travers
le paradis le plaisir éternel la
béatitude éternelle autrement dit que
nous dit la morale chrétienne elle nous
dit abstenez-vous pour le moment
elle nous dit retenez-vous car si vous
vous retenez vous irez au
Paradis or qu'est-ce que le paradis
c'est la jouissance éternelle à
l'inverse si vous ne vous retenez pas si
vous succombez à la tentation vous irez
en enfer donc la souffrance est
éternelle mais alors nous dit bentam
qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre est-ce
qu'il y aurait la bonne souffrance et la
mauvaise souffrance la bonne souffrance
c'est-à-dire la souffrance terrestre et
la mauvaise souffrance la souffrance de
l'enfer est-ce qu'il y aurait le bon
plaisir et le mauvais
plaisir le bon plaisir du paradis et le
mauvais plaisir terrestre c'est pas
cohérent ça ne devient cohérent que si
on admet que l'être humain cherche
effectivement la maximisation de son
plaisir et que la morale chrétienne est
finalement tout aussi utilitariste que
la morale de benentam quand elle dit à
ses fidèles sacrifiez vos plaisirs
terrestres car c'est le prix à payer
pour obtenir un maximum de plaisir dans
l'au-delà ce que veut dire bentam c'est
que contrairement à ce qu'elle prétend
la morale chrétienne n'est pas du tout
désintéressé
elle aussi est motivée par un intérêt
l'intérêt de la bé e éternelle quand on
dit à un croyant abstiens-toi d'être
heureux car si tu t'abstiens tu iras au
Paradis on agite sous son nez la carotte
du plaisir donc est-ce que ce n'est pas
un peu hypocrite de condamner les
utilitaristes au prétexes qui disent que
l'intérêt est une loi de la nature
humaine tout en demandant aux fidèles de
bien se comporter parce que c'est dans
leur intérêt on retrouve un peu ça dans
le Paris de Pascal vous savez cette idée
de calcul d'intérêt d'ailleurs c'était
précisément le but de Pascal le fait de
s'adresser au rationalistes pour leur
montrer qu'ils avaient tout intérêt à
croire en Dieu croyez en Dieu s'il
existe vous gagnez tout s'il n'existe
pas vous ne perdez rien vous ne perdez
rien ça se discute on perd quand même
les plaisirs terrestres oui mais à côté
du Paradis en comparaison de la
béatitude éternelle les plaisirs
terrestres c'est vraiment pas
dingue calcul d'intérêt et ça pour
benentam ça veut tout dire ça veut dire
que même la religion qui prétend
condamner l'égoïsme cet égoïsme qui nous
rendrait indigne du salut éternel c'est
pourtant ce même égoïsme qu'elle
mobilise pour inciter les croyants à la
vertu je fais la charité aux pauvres
mais en échange j'irai au Paradis je
suis abstinent mais en échange j'aurai
la jouissance éternelle donnant
donnant qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec
benam qu'on partage ou pas sa conception
de la morale chrétienne on comprend son
idée son idée c'est qu'avec la promesse
du Paradis on donne au croyants un
intérêt à agir de façon vertueuse et
donc finalement que la morale chrétienne
n'est qu'une morale utilitariste qui
s'ignore mais qu'en est-il de ceux qui
ne croient pas en Dieu et qui pourtant
suivent la morale
traditionnelle cette morale
traditionnelle qui considère l'égoïsme
comme un vice parce que s'il ne croit
pas en Dieu ce qui les motive ce n'est
pas l'espoir d'aller au paradis donc
quel autre intérêt peut les
motiver on peut trouver deux intérêts au
fait de suivre la morale
traditionnelle le premier intérêt c'est
la reconnaissance sociale celui qui agit
moralement va avoir une meilleure
réputation que celui qui agit de façon
immorale il va être mieux considéré par
ses
concitoyens par exemple la collectivité
n'aime pas
l'ingratitude donc si on veut être bien
vu par la collectivité si on veut être
inséré socialement il faut faire preuve
de gratitude il faut rendre service à
celui qui nous a rendu service la
collectivité n'aime pas
l'impolitesse donc si on veut être bien
vu par la collectivité il faut être poli
on rentre pas dans la boulangerie en
disant et la grosse donne-moi du pain ça
se fait pas la collectivité n'aime pas
la violence gratuite
elle n'aime pas les promesses non tenues
le vol la trahison
elle n'aime pas tout ce qui met en péril
l'harmonie sociale donc l'individu moral
inconsciemment va se conformer aux
attentes de la société parce qu'il ne
veut pas en être exclu
et donc il va intérioriser la morale du
groupe au point de ne même pas se rendre
compte que cette morale qu'il croit
intérieure est en fait le résultat d'une
pression
extérieure d'une pression sociale c'est
ce que Freud appellera le sur moi
c'est-à-dire l'intériorisation par le
sujet des règles et des interdits
sociaux et dont l'éducation et le moyen
d'assurer la transmission d'où le fait
qu'on dise d'un enfant qui suit les
règles sociales il est bien élevé il est
bien éduqué bien éduqué ça veut dire qui
a bien intériorisé les normes du groupe
alors qu'on soit bien d'accord
l'individu qui respecte la morale
traditionnelle par souci d'intégration
sociale n'a pas conscience que c'est
pour ça qu'il la respecte d'ailleurs
lui-même ne sait pas vraiment pourquoi
il la respecte il la respecte parce que
c'est comme ça si bien que si vous lui
posez la question pourquoi agis-tu
moralement
d'abord il risque d'être étonné par la
question parce que pour lui ça relève
d'une évidence et s'il vous répond il
vous répondra parce que parce que c'est
ce qui est bien et pourquoi c'est bien
parce que c'est bien le propre du
sentiment moral c'est d'ignorer les
raisons de son
existence le bien est le bien parce
qu'il est le bien le mal est le mal
parce qu'il est le mal et ça s'arrête là
c'est ce que bentam appelle le
dogmatisme moral qui emprint d'ailleurs
exactement le même schéma que la morale
religieuse à savoir l'argument
d'autorité une chose est bonne parce
qu'elle a été imposée comme bonne il y a
un deuxième intérêt à suivre la morale
traditionnelle c'est la bonne
conscience j'agis moralement parce que
ça me donne bonne conscience al alors là
évidemment celui qui répond ça ne se
doute pas qu'il vient de mettre le doigt
dans l'engrenage pourquoi parce que non
seulement il ne répond toujours pas à la
question de savoir pourquoi le bien est
le bien et pourquoi le mal et le mal il
ne fait que déplacer la question il ne
fait que remplacer les notions de bien
et de mal par les notions de bonne
conscience et de mauvaise conscience
donc raisonnement circulaire et puis
surtout il ne se rend pas compte qu'en
disant ça il valide lui aussi l'idée
selon laquelle on agit moralement par
intérêt
on fait le bien pour avoir bonne
conscience on s'abstient de faire le mal
pour ne pas avoir mauvaise
conscience autrement dit on suit la
morale pour dormir sur ses deux oreilles
pour ne pas éprouver de
culpabilité une notion centrale de la
morale traditionnelle la
culpabilité je fais ça parce que si je
ne le fais pas je vais me sentir
coupable
ok donc tu reconnais que tu agis
moralement par intérêt encore et
toujours
l'intérêt c'est très important de
comprendre cette idée d'intérêt à suivre
la morale l'intérêt social l'intérêt
psychologique agir moralement ça procure
une
gratification ça rassure ça
valorise ça réchauffe l'ego mais sauf
qu'on ne peut pas se l'avouer parce que
se l'avouer ce serait reconnaître que
notre sentiment moral repose sur une
fiction ce serait reconnaître qu'on fait
semblant quand l'objectif c'est d'aller
au paradis on peut encore se dire qu'on
sera jugé sur nos actes tout en faisant
TER la petite voix qui nous rappelle
qu'avant les actes il y a les intentions
mais quand on ne croit pas au Paradis on
ne peut pas se cacher derrière autre
chose que nos bonnes intentions or que
risquerait-il d'arriver si on se rendait
compte que nos bon intentions sont en
réalité le masque de notre intérêt ce
serait comme si est la branche sur
laquelle on est assis et finalement
c'est ce qui donne la meilleure clé de
compréhension de la morale de Kant la
morale de Kant est non religieuse elle
ne repose pas sur une promesse de salut
éternel or qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une
action est morale selon Kante c'est la
pureté des intentions B oui parce que
quand on a enlevé le paradis de
l'équation si on enlève en plus la
pureté des intentions il reste plus rien
ou plutôt si il reste l'intérêt il y a
une troisème raison pour laquelle on
suit la morale traditionnelle et qui
d'ailleurs est la raison la plus souvent
invoquée par ceux qui la suivent le fait
qu'il soit mal de nuire à autrui on
respecte la morale parce qu'il est mal
de faire du mal c'est très intéressant
c'est très intéressant parce que ça
rejoint exactement ce que dit Bentham ça
rejoint ce que dit benam sur trois
points premièrement qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ne pas nuire à autrui ça veut
dire ne pas le faire souffrir ne pas le
faire souffrir physiquement ne pas le
faire souffrir moralement ou même
émotionnellement donc le présupposé
c'est qu'il faut minimiser la douleur et
maximiser le plaisir si la plupart des
interdits moraux concne la souffrance
infligée à autrui c'est bien que la
morale traditionnelle considère le
plaisir comme souhaitable première chose
deuxième chose c'est ce qu'on appelle la
règle d'or traite les autres comme tu
aimerais qu'ils te traitent et qu'on
traduit généralement par ne fais pas à
autrui ce que tu ne voudrais pas qu'il
te fasse le sous-entendu de la règle
d'or c'est qu'en me comportant de façon
morale à l'égard des autres les autres
se comporteront de façon morale à mon
égard principe de réciprocité bien ça
c'est la preuve qu'il y a bien un
intérêt à agir
moralement maximiser les chances que
celui avec qui je me montre bien
veillant se montre bienveillant en
retour qu'il me rende l'appareil
conclusion il y a bel et bien un intérêt
personnel à agir
moralement troisème chose il faut
arrêter de considérer qu'une action
n'est pas morale au motif qu'elle répond
à un intérêt parce que c'est bien beau
de dire nos actions doivent être
désintéressées c'est bien beau de dire
ce qui compte ce sont les intentions
mais d'abord qui mesure les intentions
qui sonde les reins et les cœurs et
ensuite qu'est-ce que ça peut faire
qu'une bonne action comporte aussi une
part d'intérêt en quoi ça enlève quoi
que ce soit à une bonne action que parmi
les raisons qu'il y a derrière cette
bonne action il y ait le souhait ou
l'espoir d'en retirer un bénéfice est-ce
qu'il faut qu'une action soit à ce point
pure et désintéressé que si elle ne
l'était pas elle vaudrait moins qu'une
mauvaise action parce que c'est à ça que
ça conduit l'exigence de pureté des
intentions à critiquer davantage les
bonnes actions que les actions mauvaises
parce qu'elles ne sont pas pures c'est
ça pour bentam la conséquence du
dogmatisme moral
l'absurdité Bentham n'est pas
spécialement contre la morale
traditionnelle il il est pour que la
morale traditionnelle soit un minimum
honnête avec
elle-même qu'elle se regarde en face et
si elle se regardait en face elle
découvrirait ce qu'elle sait déjà à
savoir qu'elle repose elle aussi sur la
logique de l'intérêt
elle découvrirait qu'agir moralement
pour avoir bonne conscience ou pour être
inséré socialement ou par désir de
réciprocité ne sont pas des raisons
d'agir moins valables que d'agir au nom
d'une prétendue pureté une pureté qui
s'affiche d'autant plus qu'elle n'existe
pas dans les faits la vraie morale nous
dit Bentham ne doit pas être une morale
qui évalue les intentions la vraie
morale doit être celle qui évalue les
conséquences qui évalue les conséquences
en terme de
bonheur avant d'aller plus loin
récapitulons jusqu'à présent on a montré
deux choses on a montré premièrement en
quoi la morale traditionnel associer le
plaisir au vice et la vertu au
sacrifice et deuxièmement ce qui est
contradictoire en quoi la morale
traditionnelle était une morale
hypocrite en voulant nous faire croire
que la vertu réside dans la pureté des
intentions alors même que tout son
fonctionnement repose sur la logique de
l'intérêt une fois qu'on a dit ça ce
qu'il faut savoir maintenant c'est par
quelle morale benentam propose de
remplacer
la morale traditionnelle et pour le
comprendre il faut dire quelques mots
sur le contexte intellectuel de son
époque nous sommes à une époque où la
science met les cerveaux en
ébullition des savants comme la marque
sont en train de révolutionner notre
conception du vivant je rappelle que la
marque c'est le précurseur de la théorie
de l'évolution avant Darwin à l'époque
où on appelait ça le
transformisme et même si les travaux de
la marque ont été critiqués par la suite
ils ont néanmoins servi de base à la
théorie darwinienne de l'évolution donc
une forte prégance des idées
scientifiques mais aussi une forte
prégance des idées économiques en est en
plein développement de ce qu'on appelle
l'économie politique on essaie de
comprendre la logique des comportements
économiques et donc tout ça va créer un
climat un air du temps intellectuel
favorable à l'esprit scientifique
c'est-à-dire à l'approche rationnelle
des phénomènes et ça ça va donner envie
aux philosophes d'injecter de la science
dans leur réflexion quand je dis
injecter de la science je veux dire par
là parvenir à une compréhension
rationnelle des comportements humains et
Bantam fait partie de ceux qui vont
aller le plus loin dans cette démarche
puisque son projet va être ni plus ni
moins que de créer une science de la
morale c'est d'ailleurs le sous-titre de
son livre des ologie ou science de la
morale donc il y a bien cette idée de
faire de la morale une science alors
évidemment la première difficulté qui
nous aura sans doute pas échappé c'est
qu'on voit mal comment on pourrait faire
de la morale une science dans la mesure
où une science est par définition
descriptive tandis que la morale est par
définition
prescriptive autrement dit la science
porte sur des faits elle nous dit ce qui
est tandis que la morale porte sur des
normes
elle nous dit ce qui doit
être alors comment benam va-t-il
résoudre cette difficulté et bien il va
la résoudre assez facilement en nous
disant tout simplement que ce qui doit
être c'est la forme corrigé et optimisé
de ce qui est alors qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire Bentham s'intéresse à l'être
humain il s'intéresse à ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque la nature humaine et
il se demande qu'est-ce qui définit la
nature humaine qu'est-ce qui caractérise
la nature humaine il en arrive à cette
conclusion que le trait caractéristique
majeur de la nature humaine
indépendamment des cultures
indépendamment des croyances religieuses
c'est la recherche du plaisir et
l'évitement de la douleur c'est la
première phrase de son introduction au
principe de morale et de législation je
le cite la nature a placé l'humanité
sous le gouvernement de deux matres
souverains la douleur et le plaisir
c'est à elle seule qu'il appartient de
signifier ce que nous devrions faire
comme de déterminer ce que nous ferons
d'un côté le modèle du bien et du mal de
l'autre la chaî des causes et des effets
sont rivés à leur trône il nous dirigent
dans tout ce que nous faisons dans tout
ce que nous disons dans tout ce que nous
pensons tout effort que nous pourrions
faire pour nous libérer de notre
suestion ne servira qu'à laigner et à la
confirmer fin de
citation donc l'être humain tend vers la
recherche du plaisir et vers l'évitement
de la
douleur cette double inclination c'est
ça que benentam appelle l'intérêt
autrement dit l'intérêt d'un être humain
de n'importe quel être humain c'est de
maximiser son plaisir et de minimiser sa
douleur cette idée selon laquelle les
actions de l'être humain sont dictées
par l'intérêt c'est une idée qu'on
trouve déjà chez un autre auteur un
auteur du 18e siècle auquel Bentham se
réfère souvent qui s'appelle
elvesus et elvesus a résumé sa pensée
dans une formule qui est restée célèbre
je cite si l'univers physique est soumis
à la loi du mouvement l'univers moral ne
l'est pas moins à celle de l'intérêt on
peut pas être plus clair donc pour elvus
comme pour benam il est possible de
modéliser scientifiquement le
comportement des êtres humains comme il
est possible de modéliser
scientifiquement le comportement des
corps physiques les corps physiques sont
mus par une force qui est la gravitation
et bien de la même façon les corps
moraux les êtres humains donc sont mu
par une force qui est l'intérêt
l'intérêt le plaisir le bonheur tout ça
pour bentam c'est exactement la même
chose je précise parce que quand on
n'est pas familier avec le vocabulaire
de benam c'est pas du tout évident et
toutes ces notions bentom va les
regrouper sous un terme générique qui
est
l'utilité ce qui est utile c'est ce qui
est utile au bonheur c'est ce qui est
utile au
plaisir et c'est de là que vient le mot
utilitarisme
l'utilitarisme c'est la maximisation de
l'utilité c'est-à-dire de l'intérêt
c'est-à-dire du bonheur c'est-à-dire du
plaisir chez mentam tous ces mots
veulent dire la même chose maintenant il
faut quand même donner une petite
explication sur le fait que bentam
identifie le bonheur au plaisir parce
que ça non plus ça n'a rien d'évident
dans notre esprit plaisir est bonheur ça
ne recouvre pas exactement la même chose
par exemple on considère habituellement
que le plaisir c'est davantage une
sensation physique tandis que le bonheur
c'est plus un état général un état de
sérénité de joie ou de
légèreté de la même façon on va
considérer que le plaisir c'est ponctuel
c'est éphémère alors que le bonheur
c'est quelque chose de durable de
Constant bien ce que nous dit MAM c'est
que ces distinctions n'ont pas lieu
d'être pourquoi elles n'ont pas lieu
d'être parce que pour bentam le bonheur
c'est tout simplement un état de plaisir
cont
continue le problème avec la distinction
habituelle entre plaisir et bonheur
c'est qu'elle présuppose que le bonheur
serait quelque chose de supérieur au
plaisir de plus noble ou de plus digne
que le plaisir mais ça benentam le
réicuse totalement pour lui il n'y a pas
une différence de nature entre plaisir
et bonheur il n'y a pas une différence
ontologique il n'y a qu'une différence
de
perception le bonheur c'est le plaisir
d'un point de vue
idéaliste c'est le plaisir vu par des
gens qui refusent d'admettre que leur
quête du bonheur n'est en réalité qu'une
quête de plaisir maquillée en quête de
bonheur en clair pour benam le bonheur
est une fiction une fiction
imaginaire et quand on gratte un peu la
surface de cette fiction imaginaire on
s'aperçoit que ce qu'il y a derrière
c'est quelque chose d'éminemment concret
à savoir le
plaisir on va prendre quelques exemples
pour certaines personnes le bonheur
c'est être riche ce que nous dit bam
c'est que trouver son bonheur dans la
richesse c'est trouver son bonheur dans
les plaisirs que procure la
richesse dans le plaisir de jouir des
biens matériels qu'on peut s'acheter
dans le plaisir de la sécurité
financière dans le plaisir de faire des
cadeaux aux gens qu'on aime on n'aime
pas l'argent pour lui-même on aime
l'argent pour le plaisir que cet argent
nous
procure pour d'autres personnes le
bonheur ce sera l'amour ce que nous dit
MAM c'est que trouver son bonheur dans
l'amour c'est trouver son bonheur dans
les plaisirs de
l'amour dans le plaisir de la compagnie
de la personne qu'on aime dans le
plaisir de la voir sourire de sentir le
contact de sa peau
donc encore une fois ce qu'on appelle le
bonheur c'est une somme de
plaisir une somme de plaisir qu'on
regroupe sous le terme de bonheur mais
qui si on analyse concrètement ce
bonheur si on le passe à la lentille du
microscope sensoriel se décompose en
séquence de plaisir et on peut décliner
cette analyse à toutes les conceptions
du bonheur le bonheur de vivre de sa
passion c'est le plaisir de vivre de sa
passion
le plaisir de faire ce qu'on aime et
d'être payé pour ça le plaisir d'avoir
envie de se lever le matin parce qu'on
sait qu'on va passer la journée à faire
ce qu'on aime le plaisir de se sentir en
accord avec ce qu'on fait ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre sur le plan conceptuel
c'est que MAM a une approche
matérialiste du bonheur il a une
approche matérialiste de tout d'ailleurs
pas seulement du bonheur c'està-dire
qu'il cherche àid ifier les fondements
matériels de nos
abstractions or le fondement matériel
d'une abstraction nous dit benentam
c'est une
sensation l'abstraction n'est rien
d'autre que la
spiritualisation de la
sensation et ça c'est ce que ne
comprennent pas ceux qui différencient
plaisir et bonheur il ne se rendent pas
compte que l'abstraction qu'ils
appellent bonheur n'existerait pas sans
un fondement matériel qui est le
plaisir la sensation de plaisir de la
même façon la plupart des individus
pensent qu'il existe une vertu
indépendamment du fondement matériel de
la vertu qu'il existerait une vertu en
soi une morale en soi un bien en soi et
ça nous dit MAM c'est une illusion quand
on dit de quelqu'un qu'il est vertueux
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire réellement
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire matériellement
on veut dire que ces actions nous
procurent du plaisir et on invente une
abstraction la vertu parce qu'on veut
pas admettre que ce qui nous intéresse
dans la vertu ce sont les conséquences
pratiques de la
vertu pourquoi est-ce qu'on considère la
générosité comme une
vertu parce que l'individu généreux
c'est celui qui va nous offrir des
choses donc c'est celui qui va augmenter
notre plaisir
je vais prendre un autre exemple
pourquoi l'héroïsme est-il considéré
comme une vertu parce que le héros c'est
celui qui va faire à ma place ce que je
n'ai pas le courage de faire c'est celui
qui va se battre à ma place qui va
prendre des risques à ma place qui va
mourir à ma place on considère
l'héroïsme comme une vertu parce que
l'héroïsme est avantageux pour tous ceux
qui ne le sont pas héroïqu
et le héros c'est celui qui va éprouver
le plaisir d'être un héros ce qu'on
appelle la gloire la gloire
étymologiquement c'est la renommée être
renommé c'est être nommé plusieurs fois
nommé par les autres comme celui qui
s'est sacrifieré pour les autres le
héros c'est celui dont le courage est
motivé par le plaisir anticipé de passer
à la
postérité don qu'est-ce que la vertu au
sens traditionnel du terme c'est la
spiritualisation de l'intérêt c'est
l'intérêt déguisé en idéal c'est en ce
sens que benentam parle de fausse morale
la fausse morale c'est la morale qui
n'assume pas le fait que les individus
recherchent leur intérêt qui masquent
cette recherche de l'intérêt par des
prétendu valeurs qui sont en réalité des
fictions des
abstractions et qui du coup produit des
effets contraires à ceux qui étit
initialement recherché au nom de la
vertu on produit de la souffrance
inutile au nom de la vertu on produit du
sacrifice inutile et on nous fait croire
que ce sacrifice inutile est une vertu
et bien tout enjeu de l'utilitarisme ça
va être de débarrasser la morale
traditionnelle de toutes les fictions de
toutes les abstractions qui
s'intercalent entre les individus et la
MA isation du plaisir en clair le but de
l'utilitarisme c'est d'aller directement
à la recherche de l'intérêt la vraie
vertu nous dit bentam ce n'est pas
d'opposer devoir et intérêt c'est de les
faire
converger l'utilitarisme est un
conséquentialisme ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que ce qui compte moralement
ce ne sont pas les principes ce ne sont
pas les valeurs ou ou les intentions ce
sont les conséquences les conséquences
en terme de
plaisir la morale traditionnelle
valorise les individus qui ont des
principes qui ont des convictions
c'est-à-dire qui ont décidé par avance
de ce qu'il pouvait faire et de ce qu'il
ne pouvait pas faire pour bendam rien
n'est plus stupide parce qu'avoir des
principes suivre aveuglément des
principes c'est se donner des raisons
d'agir contre son intérêt quelqu'un qui
a des principes c'est quelqu'un qui dira
par exemple je refuse de prendre des
médicaments pour soulager ma douleur
question de principe mais ça veut dire
quoi question de principe qu'est-ce que
mon principe est censé m'apporter
qu'est-ce que mon principe est censé
apporter à la société parce que on peut
refuser de prendre des médicaments pour
des raisons
conséquentialistes parce qu'on a peur
des effets secondaires par exemple dans
ce cas-là notre refus n'est pas motivé
par un principe mais par un intérêt mais
dire qu'on refuse par principe ça veut
juste dire qu'on refuse sans avoir de
raison concrète de
refuser parce qu'on veut se prouver
qu'on est quelqu'un de courageux parce
qu'on estime que les médicaments c'est
pour les faibles un peu comme ce
personnage de série qui disait jamais je
ne me ferai anesthésier même sous la
torture si c'est pour ça dans ce cas-là
encore encore une fois c'est par
intérêt l'intérêt qu'il y a à se voir
comme quelqu'un de courageux l'intérêt
narcissique et pourquoi pas mais dans ce
cas-là il faut pas dire que c'est par
principe il faut assumer le fait que
c'est par éego on en revient toujours à
la même chose on fait des choses par
intérêt on recouvre cet intérêt sous un
voile de vertu et on se persuade ainsi
que notre comportement a une valeur
supérieure mais ce que nous dit bentam
c'est que ça c'est un mauvais
calcul parce que si le but le but réel
pas le but de façade si le but réel
c'est de satisfaire son intérêt autant
satisfaire directement l'intérêt qui est
à la source de tous les autres à savoir
la maximisation du
plaisir parce que recourir à des
stratégies fictionnelles pour se donner
du plaisir recourir à des fictionnelle
c'est-à-dire chercher à se prouver qu'on
est quelqu'un de courageux qu'on est
quelqu'un de généreux ou de meilleur que
les autres parce qu'on refuse la
facilité c'est une manière très
alombiquée de satisfaire son intérêt
parce que c'est satisfaire son intérêt
en faisant un détour par une fiction et
quand bam parle de mauvais calcul il
faut l'entendre au sens littéral il faut
l'entendre au sens de colonne des
avantages et de colonne des
convonvénient colonne des gains et
colonne des pertes dans la colonne des
gains on a la satisfaction de l'ego dans
la colonne des pertes on a la douleur la
douleur physique la douleur concrète
laquelle de ces deux colonnes l'emporte
pour benentam c'est très clair c'est la
colonne des pertes précisément parce que
la satisfaction de l'ego n'est pas un
vrai plaisir c'est un plaisir dérivé
c'est un plaisir
indirect la morale utilitariste c'est
celle qui préconise de recourir au
calcul le calcul hdoniste le calcul des
plaisirs et des peines pour savoir si
une action est bonne ou pas parce qu'en
définitive c'est ça la vraie question
est-ce que mon action est susceptible
d'engendrer plus de plaisir que de peine
il y en a pas d'autrees si mon action
engendre plus de plaisir que de peine
elle est bonne si elle engendre plus de
peine que de plaisir elle est mauvaise
point le reste c'est de la décoration
fictionnelle et c'est ça le problème de
ceux qui se ventent le plus d'avoir des
principes c'est qu'ils ne sont pas dans
la morale ils sont dans l'esthétique
morale or tout ce qu'on a dit depuis
tout à l'heure démontre que la vertu
n'est rien d'autre que le masque de
l'intérêt donc pourquoi continuer sinon
par dogmatisme pourquoi continuer à
accorder plus de valeur aux fictions
morales plutôt qu'à l'intérêt que ces
fictions morales recouvrent ça n'a aucun
sens ce qui a du sens c'est de peser les
avantages et les désavantag de mon
action en terme de plaisir ce qui a du
sens c'est d'anticiper les effets de mon
action et de comparer les gains
occasionnés avec les pertes
occasionnées la morale ce n'est pas une
affaire de principe c'est une affaire de
mathématique je dis souvent la morale
utilitariste c'est une arythme éthique
une éthique du calcul et tout le champ
lexical de l'économie que bentam utilise
quand il parle de maximisation des
plaisirs de minimisation des peines
quand il parle de budget moral ou de
soldes net de plaisir tout ce
vocabulaire est pour nous dire que la
vertu n'est pas tant une affaire
d'intention qu'une affaire
d'intelligence parce qu'au fond nous on
sait tous ce qui est bon pour nous et
pour les autres ce qui est bon pour nous
et pour les autres c'est le plaisir
c'est la maximisation du
plaisir seulement voilà il arrive qu'on
fasse ce que bentam appelle des erreurs
de calcul on croit maximiser notre
plaisir mais à l'arrivée on s'aperçoit
qu'on a créé plus de douleur que de
plaisir on s'aperçoit que notre plaisir
nous a coûté plus cher que ce qui nous a
rapporté par exemple si vous buvez de
l'alcool parce que ça vous procure du
plaisir mais que vous en buvez tellement
que ça vous rend malade c'est un mauvais
calcul vous aurez eu du plaisir mais la
souffrance qui va lui succéder va
l'emporter sur ce plaisir c'est pour ça
que bentam nous dit que la morale est
une affaire
d'intelligence parce que c'est une
affaire de calcul des
probabilités la vertu selon bentam la
vertu au sens de vraie vertu c'est le
bon calcul le vice c'est le mauvais
calcul celui qui boit trop fait un
mauvais calcul car il ne tient pas
compte du fait que l'excès d'alcool
engendre le contraire de ce qui a étit
recherché la morale est une affaire
d'intelligence parce que la morale
consiste dans l'anticipation des effets
à court moyen et et long terme de nos
actions se dire par exemple je vais
boire de l'alcool pour éprouver la
sensation de livresse c'est une
anticipation des effets à court terme se
dire je risque d'avoir la gueule de bois
demain matin c'est une anticipation à
moyen terme se dire à force de boire de
l'alcool je vais avoir une cirrose c'est
une anticipation à long terme l'idiotie
morale nous dit benentam c'est de
n'anticiper les effets à court terme de
notre action la sagesse morale c'est
l'anticipation à moyen et à long terme
des effets notre action et la sagesse
morale est quelque chose deile c'est
parce que l'être humain tendance à pas
anticiper les effets à long terme DEES
actions c'estàd les effets éloignés dans
le temps onit queireop peutmer notre sé
on sait mais c'est lotain
donc c'est
abstrait tout ce qui est éloigné dans le
temps nous paraît
abstrait et c'est pour ça que selon
mantham les sanctions religieuses sont
relativement
inefficaces parce que le paradis l'enfer
c'est loin tout ça tellement loin que ça
en devient
virtuel ce qui n'est pas virtuel c'est
la visite chez le médecin qui vous dit
vous avez une
cirrose là c'est concret c'est concret
quand c'est trop tard
et qu'on regrette en se disant si
j'avais su mais on savait on savait
abstraitement donc on ne savait pas
vraiment
l'intelligence c'est quand on sait que
le futur deviendra un jour
présent la première vertu morale nous
dit benentam c'est
l'anticipation ce qu'il appelle la
prudence au sens étymologique du mot
prudence à savoir prévoyance le prudent
c'est celui qui prévoit et prévoir c'est
se donner la possibilité d'agir au
présent de manière à maximiser les
bénéfices au
futur une action c'est un investissement
dans le futur la deuxième vertu morale
selon bentam c'est ce qu'il appelle la
bienveillance
effective la bienveillance effective
c'est le désir de procurer du plaisir à
soi aux autres bienveillance donc mais
qui s'accompagne des actions qui sont
supposé procurer ce plaisir la
bienveillance toute seule la
bienveillance qui ne se traduit pas dans
des actes ça sert à rien ça n'a aucune
valeur la bienveillance n'est vertu que
lorsqu'elle devient effective nous dit
bentam et c'est pour ça qu'il se moque
àaigrement de ceux qui sont uniquement
dans le discours moral plutôt que dans
l'action morale de ce ceux qui disent ça
c'est bien ça c'est mal de ceux qui
disent j'approuve je condamne parce
qu'une fois qu'on a condamné qu'est-ce
qui a changé rien de la même façon que
s'apitoyer sur le malheur de l'humanité
sans rien faire pour diminuer ce malheur
sans rien faire pour rééquilibrer la
balance morale ça n'a aucune utilité ce
n'est rien d'autre que de la
posture ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui du
signalement de vertu on s'indigne parce
que s'indigner ça coûte pas cher et que
ça permet de rehausser son ego mais dans
le fond si on était vraiment indigné on
se lèverait de notre fauteuil et on
ferait quelque chose croire que dénoncer
la souffrance va avoir pour effet de
diminuer cette souffrance c'éit pas de
la naïveté c'est de la
comédie la bienveillance n'est réelle
que si elle est effective pas oratoire
pas
ostentatoire bentam écrit je cite la
vertu n'exige pas qu'un homme se rende
témoin volontaire de peine qu'il ne peut
contribuer en rien à éloigner ou à
soulager il y a du stoicisme dans cette
conception l'idée qui ne sert à rien de
souhaiter voir advenir ce qu'on ne
contribue pas à faire advenir par ses
actes la vraie morale selon MAM n'est
pas esthétique
elle est
pragmatique une morale esthétique c'est
une morale qui sert d'abord à satisfaire
nos intérêts
psychologiques c'est une morale par
laquelle la souffrance de l'autre
devient l'instrument de notre propre
valorisation c'est une morale
d'escrro et c'est là qu'on voit
apparaître le grand paradoxe le grand
paradoxe par rapport à ce qu'on disait
au début de cet épisode sur le fait que
l'utilitarisme prendnerait
l'égoïsme car ce que nous dit benentam
c'est que la morale utilitariste se
révèle finalement beaucoup plus
altruiste que la morale
traditionnelle pourquoi parce que la
morale traditionnelle ne s'occupe pas du
bonheur des gens elle ne s'en soucie pas
alors qu'au contraire la morale
utilitariste se souci du bonheur des
gens
elles s'en soucie concrètement pas
abstraitement parce qu'il faut
absolument préciser quelque chose
quelque chose de très important qui est
que l'utilitarisme ne nous dit pas de
maximiser uniquement notre propre
plaisir il nous dit de maximiser le
plaisir du plus grand nombre parce que
ce qui compte d'un point de vue
utilitariste c'est la quantité globale
de
bonheur pas la quantité personnelle de
bonheur alors oui maximiser son propre
bonheur c'est important parce que c'est
le premier pas vers la maximisation du
bonheur global autrement dit si si
chacun travaillait à son propre bonheur
la quantité totale de bonheur serait
mécaniquement beaucoup plus élevée mais
l'utilitarisme ne nous dit pas qu'il ne
faut penser qu'à soi si j'ai de quoi me
nourrir et que je tombe sur quelqu'un
qui n'a pas mangé depuis 3 jours
l'utilitarisme nous dit donne-lui à
manger parce que qu'est-ce que ça va te
coûter un repas mais ce repas à qui
est-il le plus
utile à qui va-t-il procurer le plus de
plaisir la perte occasionnée par ce don
est-elle plus importante ou moins
importante que le gain de celui qui va
en
bénéficier le calcul est vite fait elle
est moins
importante donc il faut donner ce repas
entre celui qui a beaucoup et celui qui
n'a rien celui à qui on doit donner
c'est celui qui n'a rien quand bien même
celui qui a beaucoup ce serait nous-mêm
dans dans une perspective utilitariste
on ne personnalise pas l'intérêt on
personnalise pas l'intérêt ça veut dire
on fait passer l'intérêt global avant
l'intérêt
individuel donc c'est tout sauf de
l'égoïsme c'est de l'optimisation
collective une société utilitariste
c'est une société consciente que ce qui
ne représente pas grand-chose pour
certains représente beaucoup pour
d'autres et qu'il ne faut pas hésiter à
sacrifier un peu pour donner beaucoup
mais si l'idée c'est de sacrifier
beaucoup pour donner peu alors là ça
marche pas c'est mathématiquement
absurde et si l'utilitarisme rejette la
morale du sacrifice ce n'est pas que le
sacrifice soit nécessairement une
mauvaise chose c'est que le sacrifice
n'est pas une bonne chose en soi il est
une bonne chose quand il est
mathématiquement justif
c'est-à-dire justifié par la balance
bénéfice perte il est une mauvaise chose
quand il est mathématiquement
injustifié c'est ça
l'utilitarisme une action n'est pas
bonne ou mauvaise dans l'absolu
elle est bonne ou mauvaise dans le
contexte
elle est bonne ou mauvaise selon ses
conséquences en terme de bonheur
global la morale traditionnelle condamne
l'égoïme
mais dans les fait elle produit plus de
souffrance que de bonheur la morale
utilitariste ne condamne pas l'égoïsme
mais dans les fait elle produit plus de
bonheur que de malheur dans un cas on ni
l'égoïsme de l'homme mais on le pratique
dans l'autre cas on admet l'égoïsme de
l'homme mais on essaie d'aller
au-delà ce que nous dit bentam c'est
qu'il faut sortir de l'hypocrisie
qu'il faut admettre que nous sommes tous
égoïstes mais qu'il est possible de
dépasser notre
égoïsme de se rendre compte que notre
bonheur ne doit pas se faire au
détriment de celui des autres mais en
convergence avec celui des
autres je
cite la nature naïve et sans art porte
l'homme à rechercher le plaisir immédiat
à éviter la peine immédiate ce que peut
faire la raison c'est d'empêcher le
sacrifice d'un plaisir éloigné plus
grand ou l'infliction d'une peine
éloignée plus grande en échange de la
peine et du plaisir présent en un mot
d'empêcher une erreur de calcul dans la
somme du bonheur c'est aussi en cela que
consiste toute la vertu qui n'est que le
sacrifice d'une moindre satisfaction
actuelle qui s'offre sous forme de
tentation a une satisfaction plus grande
mais plus éloignée qui en fait constitue
une récompense supposons un homme enclin
à liv rognerie on devra lui apprendre à
examiner et à peser la somme de plaisir
et de peine qui résulte de sa conduite
il verra d'un côté l'intensité et la
durée du plaisir de l'ivresse c'est ce
qui constituera dans son budget moral la
colonne des profit par contre il lui
faudra faire entrer en ligne de compte
premièrement les indispositions et
autres effets préjudicia à la santé
deuxièmement des peines contingentes à
venir résultat probable des malad dit et
de l'affaiblissement de sa constitution
troisièmement la perte de temps et
d'argent proportionné à la valeur de ces
deux choses dans sa situation
individuelle quatrièmement la peine
produite dans l'esprit de ceux qui lui
sont chers tels que par exemple une mère
une épouse un enfant cinquièmement la
défaveur attachée au vice de livrognerie
le discrédit notoire qui en résulte aux
yeux d'autrui 6ièmement le risque d'un
châtiment légal et la honte qui
l'accompagne
comme par exemple lorsque les lois
punissent la manifestation publique de
l'insagie temporaire produite par
l'ivresse ctièmement le risque des
châtiments attachés au crime qu'un homme
ivre est exposé à commettre hèmement le
tourment produit par la craintte des
peines d'une vie future tout cela
conduira probablement cet homme à
découvrir qu'il achète trop cher le
plaisir de l'ivresse il verra que la
morale qui est la vertu et le bonheur
qui est l'intérêt personnel lui
conseille d'éviter cet excès il a à
triomphé de son intempérance le même
intérêt qu'à un homme qui dans
l'acquisition de la richesse peut
choisir entre gagner beaucoup et gagner
peu la déontologie ne demande pas de
sacrifice définitif dans ces leçons elle
propose à l'homme avec lequel elle
raisonne un surplu de jouissance il
cherche le plaisir elle l'encourage dans
cette recherche elle la reconnaît pour
sage honorable et vertueuse mais elle le
conjure de ne point se se tromper dans
ses calculs elle lui représente l'avenir
un avenir qui n'est probablement pas
éloigné avec ses plaisirs et ses peines
elle demande si pour la jouissance
goûtée aujourd'hui il ne faudra point
payer demain un intérêt usuraire et
intolérable elle supplie que la même
prudence de calcul qu'un homme sage
applique à ses affaires journalières
soit appliquée à la plus importante de
toutes les affaires celle de la félicité
et du malheur la déontologie ne professe
aucun mépris pour cet égoïsme qu'invoque
le vice lui-même elle reconnaît que
livivrom lui-même se propose un but
convenable mais elle est prête à lui
prouver que ce but l'ivrognerie ne le
lui fera pas atteindre elle part d'une
vérité qu'aucun homme ne peut ni à
savoir que tous les homme désire être
heureux elle n'a que faire de dogmatiser
despotiquement sa mission à elle est de
nous inviter à faire du bien et du mal
une sage estimation elle n'a d'intérêt à
telle ou telle ligne de conduite à tel
ou tel résultat qu'antant qu'il s'agit
d'une fraction de bonheur à retrancher
du tout tout ce qu'elle se propose c'est
de mettre un frein à la précipitation
d'empêcher l'imprudence de prendre des
mesures irréédiables et de faire un
mauvais marché elle n'a rien à objecté
au plaisir qui ne sont point associé à
une portion de peine plus qu'équivalente
en un mot elle régularise l'égoïsme et
comme un intendant actif et sage elle
administre notre reven de félicité de
manière à nous en faire retirer le plus
d'avantage possible mais elle n'est pas
aveugle et imprévoyante elle sait que le
présent sera bientôt le passé et que les
opinions de l'heure actuelle seront
modifiées par l'expérience de l'heure
qui suivra c'est pourquoi elle désire
que dans le calcul de ce qui est on
fasse entrer comme élément important ce
qui doit être ces enseignements
consistent à nous dire pesz bien tout
pesz chacune des choses qui entrent dans
le marché profitez des jouissances qui
sont maintenant à votre disposition mais
si derrière est la souffrance si en
compensation des jouissances que vous
allez vous procurer il vous faut
renoncer à des jouissances plus grandes
est-ela de la prudence si pour acheter
la jouissance que vous convoitez il vous
faut infliger à autrui une peine plus
grande que votre jouissance est cela de
la bienveillance ou si les autres vous
renvoie avec usure la peine que vous
leur infligez ou retranche de vos
jouissances une somme plus grande que
celle dont vous les privez y a-t-il
encore là de la prudence en fait
l'égoïsme qui ne tient pas compte des
choses à venir a aussi peu de prudence
que de bienveillance c'est véritablement
tuer la poule pour en avoir les œ d'or
moi seul moi seul c'est le cri d'une âme
insensible au bonheur ou au malheur
provenant de caus extérieur
l'insensibilité au mal est un avantage
évident pour son possesseur mais à la
condition qu'elle n'amènera pas de
réaction il s'est manifesté parmi les
moralistes une disposition violente à
exclure de l'âme humaine l'influence du
principe personnel pourquoi cette
répugnance à admettre comme motif ce qui
est et doit être le plus fort de tous
les motifs l'amour de l'homme pour
lui-même pourquoi repousser le sentiment
personnel c'est par une sorte de pudeur
une disposition à considérer le principe
d'où découlent tous les actes toutes les
passions de l'homme comme la partie
honteuse
mais quand on a admis une fois CEPE
qu'une attention éclairée pour l'intérêt
personnel est la meilleure garantie
d'une bonne conduite ds l on sauraitter
que lanaissance et la pratique de morale
n fait de considérable progs et c'est
alors un délicieux spectacle que de
suivre du la marche lente mais visible
de
latu qu onense
àégïense pas
àreprï
on pense d'abord à l'égoïsme des autres
à celui qui a gagné une grosse somme
d'argent et qui ne l'a pas partagé avec
nous à celui qui a pris la dernière part
du gâteau sans savoir si je la voulais à
celui qui se permet d'être heureux sans
se demander si moi je suis heureux
l'goïste c'est celui qui ne pense pas à
moi et et si on prend le temps d'y
réfléchir d'y réfléchir de façon honnête
on s'apercevra que c'est effectivement
comme ça qu'on conçoit
l'égoïme on condamne l'égoïme des autres
sans se rendre compte que ce qui nous
gne dans l'égoïme des autres c'est qu'il
ne tient pas compte de notre
égoïme
l'égoïme c'est comme le morceau de
salade coincé entre les dents c'est chez
les autres que ça se remarque
si la pensée utilitariste peut nous
aider à quelque chose c'est à comprendre
que le problème ne vient peut-être pas
de l'égoïsme mais de ce qu'on en fait
est-ce que par égoïsme on cherche à être
heureux ou est-ce que par égoïsme on se
réjouit du malheur des
autres est-ce que par égoïsme on cherche
à améliorer le monde parce qu'on sait
qu'on en bénéficiera aussi où est-ce que
par égoïsme on cherche à nuire au monde
pour exprimer notre
colère est-ce que notre égoïsme désire
le bonheur des autres ou leur
malheur dans les deux cas il s'agit bien
d'égoïsme mais dans un cas l'égoïsme
nous porte à la
bienfaisance tandis que dans l'autre il
malfaisance penser à soi ne veut pas
dire ne penser qu'à soi et peut-être
qu'à vouloir condamner ce qui nous
apparaît comme de l'égoïsme chez l'autre
on se rend dépendant de sa
volonté dépendant de ses actions au
point d'en oublier que notre bonheur
dépend d'abord de
nous-même peut-être qu'à exiger des
autres qu'il soit présent pour nous
disponible pour nous dévoué à nous on en
oublie cette règle
fondamentale à savoir que le bonheur est
une chose beaucoup trop précieuse pour
la confier à quelqu'un d'autre que nous
je vous
[Musique]
remercie